good evening
members and uh welcome to the strategy
and resources committee meeting
on tuesday the 15th of june 2021
my name is councillor richard siddall
and i am the chairman of this committee
before we commence the business of the
meeting there are a few housekeeping
issues to run through
members the setup of the meeting has
been designed
to mitigate for covid therefore can ask
all
present to work in the protocols agreed
by the council
on the 29th of april 21. in the interest
of member and
officer safety we are streaming live
at this meeting as well as being
recorded and by being present
at the meeting you are consenting to be
recorded
memphis office during each item please
put your hand up to
indicate if you wish to speak
i will then invite you in turn to
participate during the meeting because
of the numbers
that we are limited to in the chamber
there will be some logistical issues
in terms of the officers and the
officers presentations
so therefore there will be movement of
the officers so we may have to wait
uh a little while before officers take
change places so that we can accommodate
them
at those particular times uh when
invited to speak please remove your mask
put on your visor turn on your
microphone and speak clearly
please reference a page number or
paragraph number when referring to the
agenda papers
keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
and ensure your microphones remain off
when not
speaking finally can i draw your
attention to the notices in the agenda
about the different levels within the
room and the fire escapes
the other item that i will drink as as
it's a warm evening
in the chamber feel that it's if
it's not necessary if gentlemen want to
feel that they want to take their
jackets off and their ties off
please feel free to do so because it is
a very warm evening
thank you so much to
item number two apologies for absence
may have the apologies please tara thank
you chairman apologies we received from
councillor boys and councillor stamp and
councillor edwards is attending as a
substitute for councillor stamp
thank you thank you tara so we now move
on to
item number three the minutes of the
meeting on the 23rd of january 21-1
the minutes of the special meeting held
on that day
are found on pages 5 to 124
and are approved as a true and accurate
record
i see move do i have a second to please
thank you that is councillor swain
if any if any member wishes to raise an
item of accuracy
please state so now
okay thank you very much members
do we agree those minutes by ascent or
do we take a vote
thank you members um
chairman i can't vote i wasn't it was a
previous meeting
yeah that's fine thank you council
edwards
so item number four is disclosure of
interest to disclose the existence
and nature of any dispos disposable
pecuniary interest
and or non-pecuniary interest related to
items on the business of the agenda
having regard to paragraph
six to eight inclusive of the code of
conduct four members
members are reminded that they are
required to disclose any
such interests as soon as they become
aware should the need
arise throughout the meeting
are there any disclosures of interest
counselor durham uh chairman a a number
of interest as a member of essex county
council although i don't think
anything on the agenda is pertaining to
that organisation there is tonight
thank you councillor durham any other
peculiar non-procurement interests
okay thank you very much i know moving
on to
item number five which is public
participation i can advise
that we have not received any
submissions from members of the public
so therefore i move to item number six
on the agenda
which is ict strategy for 2021
to 2026. we move to
that which is found on pages 120
this thing can't see all the time 125 to
136
uh we have council
officers uh leslie mr leslie and mr
hulley
to present on this particular item and
the recommendations to the council i set
out the report are as follows
to the council that the malden district
ict strategy
21-26 for the appendix one for the
distribution to all staff giving support
and guidance to management on future ict
projects
and planning be agreed
do i have a seconder i can't see with
this one i'm afraid
councillor swain thank you council swain
so i'd now like to move to
mr holly or mr leslie to present the
report
yep thank you chairman following the end
of the previous ict strategy which ran
out in
2020 a new strategy has been written to
support malden in both the
transformation and the new hybrid
working model
this strategy focuses on the completion
of a set of projects to enable the
council to work more flexibly
whilst having a focus on security
through this work ict aimed to
streamline the in-house systems
showing faster more reliable data access
the projects listed are already budgeted
for in the medium-term financial
strategy
including the server replacement which
is highlighted as an essential piece
of work thank you
leslie do we have any questions for
members about this particular item
counselor channel
uh thank you jeremy can you hear me with
my mask on yep
okay um i can't find the pager now which
is always the way but in the report i
think it did say that members laptops
um within the last year we'd all got the
new laptops
i may be recalling incorrectly but i
because i've covered
19 and everything i can't recall i think
i thought i had this laptop for a while
longer
and it does say there's a three-year
recyclable program so
is that wholly accurate that all members
have within the last year
had a new dell laptop
mr holly thank you chairman
um simply put members haven't had new
laptops in the last year
however we would like to start a rolling
cycle which is
what this project is about so we've now
listed that under hardware i think it's
page 132
where it mentions now staff and members
and speaks about a rolling cycle over
three year period
that would kick off as of 2021 so now
one of the things that when we had the
discussion about the report at the
meeting
was to ensure that as well as officers
that members were reflected
throughout the report and also taken
into account in terms of the report so
that's
you know that was amended before that
report came to the committee to ensure
that members are also reflected
in the renewal of equipment so it's good
that we are moving that forward
any other questions
councillor jarvis thank you jim
um just with regards to cost i know that
uh we've been told that it's obviously
in the budget and i can see on page one
five
one three five uh this will reoccurring
cost of half a million
five three four okay um
and uh it's not immediately clear though
could you just explain how much the
whole thing is going to cost
over sort of five year period
mr hulley thank you again um so
yes the figure five three four three
zero zero on page 135
is based on last year's expenditure from
the point of view of
things like the hardware renewal and the
host servers that
chris has mentioned and basically every
other project listed in here
those have now been factored into each
subsequent future year
so as an example the three year rolling
cycle for laptops
is around 45 000 per year
however that has a financial breakdown
in a separate document
so we do have full figures for the ict
department
but this particular figure is only for
last year it just has a total
yeah thank you shannon for major escape
back on that
so the the the 534 is really a sort of
indicative number for an annual cost
so could you if you've projected forward
for the duration of the project have you
got a sum number an aggregate number you
could just let us out
uh again off the top of my head i don't
i could find that document though so you
would have to do that outside of that
it's probably about sort of three and a
half million or something is it that
sort of over five years yes
okay if we if probably if the committee
could have that
summary circulated i'd be grateful thank
you chairman
thank you councillor durham yeah thank
you very much chairman
i wonder if i could just ask the officer
if he knows how many members don't have
any
um hardware at all i know there are a
few i'm one
as far as i'm aware all members have
some form of hardware be that a tablet
or a laptop
obviously one of the things that we do
want to address over the coming
subsequent years
is that if a member specifically
requests for example a laptop
they can get that as opposed to i
believe tablets which a lot of members
have at the moment well
i think you want to come back yeah you
can update your information because i
don't have any mdc hardware at all
but i'm not comfortable with that okay
so
obviously counselor dumb if you do
require it i'm sure
the council will supply that to you uh
councillor thompson
thank you chairman um same as council
durham really um
i use my own kit um because i prefer to
it's absolutely not that it's been i've
been refused or
let down in any way but as it happens i
don't have any
okay mdc kit thank you i
i think though where is it is available
if members want it though that's a
crucial thing isn't it mr
yeah thank you german if i took another
piece of kit home i would be thrown out
any other questions
no okay thank you very much uh so what i
would like to do
is uh move those recommendations and can
we agree those by ascent
oh okay so we have to go to council as
well yeah okay so
that will obviously then go to council
that will be in july
yes yep okay
thank you very much mr holly
so we now move to agenda item 7 which is
the
workforce and community equality
diversity and inclusion statement
of policy found on pages 136
to 160. uh mr leslie and
mrs is it mrs brown or miss
miss brown would you like to come
through thank you very much
who are going to present the report
thank you so the council is committed to
being an inclusive employer and
providing inclusive
services to the community this equality
diversity inclusion policy assists with
that commitment and to ensure the
council meets its duty under the
equality of act 2010.
three officers from the council
from hr communities and customer
services have reviewed and refreshed
the policy as a result the policy has
moved from being
only internally focused to also looking
externally to engage with partners
and building on this strong partnership
working that has taken place
over the past year three objectives
have been set to assist in achieving
their visions of the policy one team
champions
as well as equality diversity and
inclusion champions will support the
activities to meet the objectives with
learning and development to support
their roles
the three officer group will also
continue to meet to drive forward
the recommendations and the group
is also complemented by the addition of
a committee
member as part of the recommendations to
this report
who will also be able to feed back to
members
the equality impact assessment for this
policy
is also attached
thank you mr leslie um spring would you
like to
add anything to that yeah so just to say
it's been a really good opportunity to
reflect on this policy
and had the
thank you very much yeah and i i think
it's a fantastic policy and
again we mended the recommendations to
include
representation from the members which i
thought was was important as well
and the fact that we are including the
the community
as well so the two recommendations are
set out and the report are as follows
recommendation little one that the new
equality diversity and inclusion policy
attached at pendleton's one to be
adopted that a member of the strategy
and resources committee is nominated to
join the equality diversity
and inclusion officer working group do i
have a second to please
counselor sway thank you
uh thank you so i will now invite
members to
comment on the report
okay no comments at all okay
it is a fantastic report it is a
fantastic report and it's and it can be
it should be commended by the officers
who've done the work
so when it comes to a recommendation
little
two can i have a uh
proposal for who the representation is
council
uh councillor thompson was first thank
you
um councillor chana i would like to
nominate please chairman
i'd like to second thank you um i have
got a little spiel i'm afraid i had to
write it out because
it is actually pretty impressive and one
thing i've already checked with her
and i know she doesn't mind me saying
that council channel is in fact disabled
um and she's also had
i can't find it now a great experience
with
with swans which is a support group
with mind with
uh other well selection of other bodies
and
and i think she could you know being
able to see things from both sides of
the
coin as it were i think she would be an
ideal person so
thank you for that cancer thompson thank
you
do you have any other any uh
recommendations
counselor suede yes i would like to
consider nominating
yourself counselors said all of us you
have a great interest in this area
thank you very much do you have a
seconder for that
please okay thank you
so the first so we will have to take
these recommendations in
uh separately then as we have two uh
nominations for the the second
recommendation so
um recorded vote please chairman okay
okay i can have a seconder for that
please
so councillor thompson uh so if we move
to item
number one do we want to record and vote
for that or can we agree that by ascend
no i think we agreed number one was a
good report
okay thank you very much so
item number two we've had a recorded
vote tara so
could we take a roll call please yes
thank you members
so this is a relation to the nomination
for council mrs channel to sit on the
member working
the officer working group if you could
just indicate thought against rob stone
please when i call your name
um starting with cancer mrs chandler
please four council mrs chunner thank
you
councillor durham thank you councillor
jarvis
um thank you councillor lagan
thank you council shawnee
councillor against cancer swain
and we've got councillor edwards yeah
councillor mrs thompson
councillor miss white four councillor
edwards
chairman the results of that are five in
favor five against and no abstentions
okay so i have the casting vote and i'm
afraid i have to vote against
uh so do we now have to take the second
vote yeah we'd need to so
members again uh this is voting now for
uh councillor siddal
and if you could just indicate four
against abstain when i call your name
starting with council mrs chandler
please
uh i'm afraid i know the chairman's done
the casting vote against but i will have
to go against
councillor siddal thank you very much in
the interest of
what the body is about uh casadorum
thank you councillor jarvis
thank you councillor lagan cancer
shaunicy
councillor siddall four councillor swain
four councillor mrs thompson
councillor miss white against and
councillor edwards
the chairman the results of that are
five in favor four against and one
abstention
thank you chairman so before we move on
i i would just like to say that i
i know that council channel would have
been excellent in that role
and and i'm i'm yeah i feel that i have
a good background as well um in terms of
equality and diversity
and and so therefore yeah i think both
of us would be would have been
uh good representation on on that
particular working group and thank you
for putting yourself forward counselor
channel
i didn't counsel mrs thompson thank you
councillor
for putting councillor china forward
yeah do you think it would it would
diversify it too much or
because it would sway the representation
yeah i think because there are only
three officers i think if we then have
two
members it's and it is yeah the officers
are
representing both the community and the
and the officers of the council so i
think it's
best that we keep it as three and one
but thank you for that
yeah thank you very much chairman sorry
can i just have my comments recorded
against um
that advice thank you very much i don't
necessarily agree
for reasons i wish to keep to myself
obviously because the nature of my
um uh situation perhaps i felt i would
be qualified to actually add sunny to it
but
obviously uh that's not the case um from
the officer's advice thank you
okay thank you councillor janna
okay mrs brown thank you very much for
attending this evening
thank you
okay so we now move on to i agenda eight
item eight uh which is statement of
community involvement
founders are found on pages 161
100 uh mr dodson
i believe that you are going to present
this report
uh thank you chairman um actually i'm
i'm not going to present it
i'm going to hand over to mr winslow
who's been leading the
our planning policy and the the review
of the ldp
and um in fact the next two papers refer
to planning policy and mr winslow we'll
present them thank you
thank you mr wizard and welcome to the
committee and welcome to the your first
meeting in the chamber so
if you would like to present the report
thank you chairman
um the statement of community
involvement or
sci is a state is a statutory document
prepared by the council as the local
planning authority
for the mauden district it sets out how
the council will consult and engage with
the community
with planning professionals and other
stakeholders such as the environment
agency
on planning matters spanning from
preparing the local development plan
and supporting parishes with
neighbourhood plans consulting on
planning applications and engaging
people as necessary in planning
enforcement
the current sci or statement of
community involvement was approved in
november 2008
2018 and an addendum was made in march
2020 that allowed for procedural changes
needed due to covid19 restrictions
it is good practice to review the sei
frequently
and the council is required legally to
review it every five years
whilst the next review is not due until
2023
now that the council has committed to
review the local development plan
it is good to review it now so that the
scis spans the whole ldp review
timetable
the update has enabled us to link the
sei better to the refreshed corporate
plan
which council adopted in march 2021
it has been slimmed down to contain the
critical information that is needed
which has made it easier to read and
understand and unnecessary content about
internal processes has been removed
work has taken place as well with
development management officers
and the lead specialist for place to
ensure that the section that covers
the functions relating to planning
applications and enforcement
reflect the statutory requirements and
the sei
is now consistent with the information
that morden district council carries
on its website in addition further
advice has been included in the sei
as to what are or are not planning
considerations
to help people comment more effectively
on planning applications
as you'll know chair the planning policy
working group considered the sei
at its meeting on the 27th of march 2021
subject to committee approving the sei
for consultation this evening
the consultation will begin on thursday
the 17th of june
and it will run for six weeks until the
29th of july
before a final report would go to
council for adoption
thank you was that march or may mr
monson
the planning policy working group yeah
uh may
maybe he said march oh did i thank you
i'm sorry
okay thank you very much uh so the
recommendation has set out in the
reports as follows
that the statement of community
involvement at appendix a
is approved for consultation purposes do
i
have a second please counsel this way
thank you uh i will now invite members
to make any comments on the report
members councillor lagan
yeah thank you chair i don't know um
whether
this um could be confirmed by the
officer because obviously it's a big
learning process
and one it's a very good good report
very good plan um
but what informs the plan um i'm
understanding is the ldp
and other informative documents etc and
um
one thing i was thinking of earlier
today was about the
the recent council needed a local uh
housing needs survey
to identify what the the needs of the
district actually were when the deadline
for that information was
was the 12th of the 9th 2020. um
i can't see any uh detailed information
so i'd like to
to get hold of that information for
clarity so that we do know exactly what
the housing needs responses were
and why i asked that is really
there was a recent meeting a planning
where a specific large application was
made and rejected
and it would be really really good um to
have the clarity to understand
what the needs actually are to be
informed on the consultation that we're
going to be going out
to relevant stakeholders so more of a
a statement plus a question plus a
request um
i thought i might as well get them all
in thank you
for someone's election thank you chair
um
so um you're quite route councillor
lagan that
local housing needs assessment has been
commissioned i was commissioned last
year
that work is still ongoing at the moment
there's been some
there's been a need to to
review and reflect on the information
that's come back from the
council's housing needs consultants
but that being said that work will come
back to
well it will become eventually to this
committee
and it will also go before the planning
policy working group
which council has set up to consider the
details and depths of
the local development plan so in time
that information will of course as well
be published
council legend thank you mr winslow and
time bound you know how long because
pieces of string
i don't to have to date the program that
that will that that particular report
will go to the planning policy working
group
but the intention is to go out to issues
and options consultation
on the ldp review this autumn so it
would need to be before then
cancer durham oh
thank you thank you i think cancer
channel had their hand up first oh she's
sorry
i'm fine i'm i'm happy for cancer
chocolate so i apologize um
thank you thank you chairman i'm just
wondering i think it's a very good
report but i'm wondering if whether due
to the
impending review of the planning system
whether this is going to be out of date
before it's completed
we have things like the proposed
abolition of the duty to cooperate as
part of the
um planned review and of course the the
the different categorizations of
of land one of which will mean that
planning commission won't be so it won't
be required it will be an automatic
um right to build so i'm just wondering
same goes actually for our review of the
ldp whether whether we are
um jumping the fences before
and and rather wasting some time but
i'll let the officer comment
mr winslet uh thank you um in terms of
um the planning bill um the planning
bill that was in
the queen's speech this year yes there
are
proposed changes several ideas that are
coming forward as about how the planning
system might change over the course
of the next few years as it stands at
the moment this is your current
legal responsibility and
the statement of community involvement
which is the purpose of this report
is covering your current
responsibilities as a local planning
authority
you are legally required to keep the sei
up to date um in respects of the
matter of um the the planning system
might be changing and it might affect
the duty to cooperate
the duty to operate is a separate legal
matter that
although the sci does does mention the
duty to cooperate it mentions it to
provide the context of engagement
as opposed to um it's stipulating how
the duty uh needs to be discharged
that's in the next item before this
committee
thank you just come back yeah so we're
obliged to
to go through this process but it still
might be superseded by the
whatever happens in parliament that's
fine i don't need a response
okay council channel um thank you
chairman
um on page 174 and it is regarding
the area that covers the pre-application
process
just a matter of clarification in the
light of various discussions i've been
involved in recently
um it does say at 4.7
all strategic proposals must
be presented to a meeting of both
members and officers in order to
commence early member engagement
and then defines what strategic sites
are which obviously is defined also
within our constitution of the council
just on that subject matter is that
subject to
the application applicant requesting
a pre-application session
or is it has to be because the wording
is all strategic proposals
must be presented so i'm asking if
there's the qualification of it's only
in the case the applicant
desires one or that seems very
prescriptive
and indicates to me that indeed any
strategic proposal should
be presented well must be presented to
members
and officers in order to commence early
member engagement and there might be a
reason i'm asking that chairman
okay mr winslow would like to answer
that um i may need to call upon some
colleagues
here if i can't answer this completely
but
um the s this part of the sei is dealing
with pre-application advice
so if the applicant does not request
a pre-application i don't believe that
clause would be triggered
mr lee has read through as the lead
specialist of place has read through the
statement of community involvement
before it's come to committee i don't
know if
mr dodson or mr holmes um wants to add
anything else to that
this is awesome through you chairman
just to confirm that that's my
understanding
too okay counselor channel did you want
to
um well that's helpful chairman i did
want that clarification i think it might
be advantageous
if that is the case that that is made
clear in the light of something i'm
aware of recently that happened when
there was members
questions seeking some advice um
so i think i would just point that out i
have a subsequent question
um regarding the the councils that um
on the list if you like um i think it
was this
okay any other members
no okay uh
so the recommendations are that
the draft the statement of community
involvement is is approved
can we agree that by ascent or do we
have a recorded vote
okay thank you for members
we now move on to agenda item nine which
is the duty to cooperate cooperate
strategy
approval to consult found on pages
183-200
mr winslow is over to you again if you'd
like to present the report
thank you chairman as the committee will
be aware on the 23rd of february 2021
the council agreed to review its local
development plan
there are a number of legal duties and
risks associated with this project
one of which is called the duty to
cooperate in 2011 the planning and
compulsory purchase act was amended
and established new legal duties on
local authorities and some other
prescribed public bodies in
england to cooperate with each other to
address strategic
and cross-boundary matters these are
identified in the national planning
policy framework as being
those of planning for housing employment
retail
leisure and commercial developments
infrastructure for transport
telecoms security waste management water
supply
wastewater flood risk coastal change
management and the provisions of
minerals and energy
community facilities such as health
education and culture
and the conservation and enhancement of
the natural built and historic
environments
to this end a duty to cooperate strategy
has been prepared for malden district
which follows current best practice and
ties well into the updated corporate
plan
particularly the core value of
collaborate to deliver
it sets out a framework for who the
council will make every effort to
cooperate with
how it will seek that cooperation when
and what mechanisms it will put in place
to ensure the cooperation occurs
constructively actively and on an
ongoing basis
which is a requirement of national
policy this in turn will support the
council when the ldp review is subject
to the examination in public by a
planning inspector
and help to achieve a judgment that the
ldp is both lawful
and effective as set out in the report
regulations establish who are the bodies
that must comply with the duty
and they include all of our neighbouring
authorities essex county council
the environment agency nhs bodies
the marine management organisation and
the south east local enterprise
partnership amongst many others
the approach advocated by the strategy
and supported by national planning
guidance
is that the council will then enter into
statements of common ground
as the ldp review is prepared to
document and track the cooperation on
strategic issues affecting each
cooperation
body in the hope that all matters can be
resolved
by the time the odp review is submitted
to the government and examined
the planning policy working group
considered the draft strategy at its
meeting on the 27th
of may 2021 and discuss the number of
matters as documented in the reports
should the committee approve the
strategy for consultation it will be
sent to the
duty to cooperate bodies for a targeted
consultation
for six weeks which will then help
inform the final strategy and the
council's approach to the duty in future
thank you mr winslow uh so the
recommendations are sat
out in the report are as follows little
one that the draft duty to cooperate
strategy has set out in appendix a
for a targeted consultation with all
other duty to cooperate
bodies be approved little two that the
following consultation and updated
duty to cooperate strategy be brought
back to the strategy and resources
committee
with appropriate amendments for final
approval
do i have a second to please councillor
swain thank you very much
uh do would any members like to comment
on this report i'm sure counselor
channel does cancel a channel
yes thank you chairman um i'll go back
um
to the question i was going to ask and
of course it wasn't the last report
and it's to do on page 184 chairman and
it is 33
sorry 3.3.1 and it's about duty to
credit
bodies and all those bodies listed and
it seems like every um
council in essex has been included
including
tharak brentwood and epping um so
i question that um in terms of does it
need
um to be entirely encapsulating all of
the all ethics authorities
or are those closer to our borders if
you like
or is it i know there is one council
there who i think is seeking assistance
in actually delivering
their housing requirements and um i've
got
two months the mayor of london i see is
a council team
um and obviously i'm aware
of how this council's approached
previously and how the essex authorities
got together and the response they did
bearing in mind the mayor of
london wanted who had not provided for
enough housing numbers in his own
authority
seek sought to engage district councils
or rather through the counties and
housing that he failed to perhaps
put in his plan and for us to look at
that i'm appreciating that might come
into the equation again
and also can i ask bearing in mind the
importance of broadband
and in perhaps you know the electric
gender now by the government
um should be uk not be a consultant on
this bearing in mind the program
for um across the nation but also of
course essex county council
has the superfast essex team that is
actually implementing in essex
part of the bduk program and also
therefore bearing in mind the electric
viewpoint of the government now in
electric vehicles and phasing out diesel
and petrol i mean i might not be seen
totally as a planning issue but as if
we're talking about
um you know charging points and
everything in properties
um should someone like ev electric i
think there's a body called that who
delivers all news from the
electric vehicle world so i just ask
those questions chairman if i may on the
bodies
um detailed within that element of the
report thank you very much thank you
council chair mr winslow
thank you um so in terms of all of the
authorities
and you're quite right cancer channel it
sees all of the authorities in
the greater essex area including the two
unitaries of south end and thorac
the reason for that is that the
strategic issues have already been
identified
at an essex level that relate to
specifically
essex sorry it's relate specifically to
gypsy and traveler transit sites
so that is that that is uh that is a
matter which has been
going on for a little while now trying
to explore
uh where in essex transit sites could be
located and that is a standing item on
most local plans across the county
um in terms of the neighbouring
authorities
clearly they will be the ones that are
more interested in some of the cross
boundary matters
uh that would otherwise come up in the
ldp review
in terms of the mayor of london this is
an interesting one so
you have no choice but to cooperate with
the mayor of london
in the sense of the regulations uh you
are
as the local planning authority required
to cooperate with the mayor of london
interestingly the mayor of london is not
required to cooperate
back um because the london
the the legislation that covers the
mayor's planning powers
is slightly different um but um as
councillor chana refers to there has
been
quite a lot of work over the last four
or five years as the london plan has
been prepared
which has involved the east of england
local government association on behalf
of malden
to try to ensure that the the matters
that
the mayor and the greater london
authority have been considering as part
of the london plan preparation
um are have been have had information
fed from the districts
all around the home counties
in terms of broadband infrastructure
and if i take the other one as well
about electric
or any other utilities we don't have a
duty to cooperate
with those bodies um they are
not necessarily a um
a a body which um
they're not a body which the act
requires us to cooperate with however
they may fall into one of the statutory
consulties of the local development plan
which is covered by the statement of
community involvement that you've just
approved for consultation
so it's not the duty to operate is very
specific
um whereas other bodies are consulted
and engaged as part of plan preparation
but are covered under different
regulations okay
council channel i'm a supplementary then
chairman
can then the officer please advise the
list we have before us
does that include all the bodies we have
to consult with or are
any optimal in terms of being able to be
left out
so are there any that are on the list or
whichever way you look at it
have not been included i guess that's
where i'm coming from in light of what
you've just said
about the duty to cooperate and then
others through the statement of
community involvement
mr wesley uh thank you uh yes all the
bodies are prescribed
on 3.3.1 okay thank you
excuse me counselor well thank you i i
just wish to
wish the officer good luck with the duty
of cooperate because as councillor chana
will recall
prior to the last ldp um our closest
neighbours to the west
uh the city council objected so
i'm rather hoping that the duty
cooperate is abolished in the autumn
because our so-called friends and
neighbours uh have been
have singularly failed to cooperate in
the past we shall see
thank you council durham councillor
white thank you mr chairman um
yeah i was just what council durham said
it was quite amusing that a very
close um council decided they wanted to
support one of the planning applications
as long as they could have all the
affordable housing for their residents
the other thing i'm a bit surprised
about is the travelers
because we are obviously part of the
essex travelers group
which obviously pay into and i would
have thought that a lot of the
work has already been done via that so i
think we should look into that because
that should save a lot of time
because we're all working together
anyway all the people who are members of
it
so i don't know if that's been taken in
or not
is that the case mr winslow um so yes we
are part of the essex
um uh traveller unit uh essex county
traveler unit
they are focused on the enforcement of
of any unauthorized incursions on land
across public
land in essex we're also part of however
as part of the
council's membership of the essex
planning officers association
we are members of um we're members of
that body and
that body commissions evidence in
respects of gypsy and traveller needs
and also as part of the investigations
of transit need
which is which is quite a distinct need
does it's not a need that's necessarily
ever present everywhere
in essex um but certainly um
the intelligence that comes from the
essex planning uh sorry essex trap gypsy
and traveller unit
is utilized in the ldp okay thank you
before i go back to canada any other
members would like to see mr speak
counselor swain thank you sherman um
where do um uh utilities come
in under standard consultation water
supply electricity supplies on
uh they're in british surely um highly
important for
future planning purposes i think that
goes back to what you said before isn't
it mr winslow
it does yes i'm so just just uh just
that emphasis again that these are the
bodies we're required to cooperate with
for the purposes of the of the planning
legislation
um in respects of utilities telecoms etc
that's
not to diminish their importance at all
but they're just
the engagement of them is covered under
different regulations and not the duty
to cooperate
thank you council durham thank you it
was uh an answer in response to
councillor miss white actually um
for my sins i now chair the essex county
traveler unit
um and uh and the
transit sites aren't part of our remit
in fact unfortunately the lack of
transit sites
is is it makes it more difficult for us
to move on in some cases
but as the officer has said that the
essex
planners association is looking um and
have been looking at
potential travelers science quite a long
time
can you counsel durham any other members
okay uh what i would like to do then uh
is to move the
mo the recommendation uh can we agree
that by ascent
thank you very much
so we now move on to item number 10
which
is to appointment of representatives on
the liaison committees
found on pages 201 and 202.
i'm going to go straight to the
recommendations the recommendations are
sat
out in the report is as follows that the
committee appoints
representatives to the bodies the car
parking task and finish working group
the places for people liaison committee
the river crouch coastal community team
management team
the waste member task and finish working
group
and the current representation is listed
in the report
so therefore can i have a secondar that
that representation
uh stays the same unless there are any
any alterations cancer swaying
okay uh
can we agree that by ascent agreed thank
you very much
i'd only be proposing the names anyway
that they're the the uh
the prospect of having all these waste
members
in fact be the members
waste time finish
[Laughter]
i don't know it depends on how you want
to interpret it i just have a feeling
that
this isn't what we used to call it it
was called the waste contract was it
right okay okay i think it was that a
couple of years ago this one that i had
it's been what that since i've been
remembered so
um so uh can we agree that via ascent
yes yes that's fine okay uh
so item number 11 is any either items of
business that the chairman of the
committee decides are urgent and there
are none
so i'm into item number 12 which is the
closure of the meetings thank you
members for your contributions this
evening i now draw this meeting to a
close
at 8 17. as the meeting is now closed
members are advised not to enter into
any further discussions on this forum
and to please leave the meeting behind
me promptly
thank you very much